radio stations across the u.s. have been
dropping the Christmas classic baby it
is cold outside from playlists following
a backlash from listeners critics are
complaining that the song in which a man
attempts to persuade a woman to spend
the night with him is not in keeping
with modern values and flies in the face
of the meaty movement the track there
was first recorded for the 1949
Hollywood film Neptune's daughter and
quickly became a hit to winning an Oscar
for Best Original Song
the following year since then it has
been covered by tens of artists but me
two activists say that the lyrics
normalised manipulative and coercive
behavior others claim though that
critics misunderstand the song and argue
that to be consistent lots of others
would also have to be dropped from radio
playlists baby it's cold outside is
basically a date rape song I'm glad
people are finally realizing this here
is your annual reminder that baby it's
cold outside
it's basically a date rape song they
won't play baby it's cold outside
because it implies rape but they can
play this horrible rap music that talks
about sex drugs shooting people etc
these other holiday songs must also be
removed as they're offensive as well I
saw Mommy Kissing Santa Claus subjecting
minors to softcore porn white Christmas
racist Santa Baby gold digger blackmail
we discussed the story with the legal
analyst Jennifer Braden and also the
former candidate for New York City
Council Marni alasa this is something
that is creating such an uproar we can't
ignore it and also maybe it's reflecting
that things need to change and that you
know maybe maybe things have maybe
Christmas carols also has to evolve with
our society there are a lot of important
issues right now and when we we focus on
songs like this
trying to get it out I mean we're
painting a message that me too has just
become unhinged and going after these
Christmas songs from the 1940s which yes
was a different era but frankly nobody
nobody has cared about and so the me2
movement wants to stay wants to stay
current and relevant then I think that
we need to focus on the main issues the
biggest issues and stay away maybe from
some of the lesser things like some of
these Christmas songs I think there's a
lot of outrage I think women are really
really angry the argument that maybe
this is a little bit overkill I think
you have to look at that and see kind of
what is behind that and what's behind it
is you know women want relief Ramona
want change women want their voices
heard I've been reading into the lyrics
of the song and also some some other
analysts and commentators have been I've
been reading about this it's very
interesting to see the different takes
Marnie's you said it's really a question
of interpretation isn't it it can be
taken in different ways I mean I think
if you're a survivor of rape you're
going to interpret it that way as a date
rape song I think most people aren't
going to study that it's from the 1940s
and you know you could make an argument
that says that this is a woman who's
celebrating for sexuality and it's
really a flirty again and I understand
the arguments and I do understand both
sides of this argument I just see really
the need to focus on on some of the
bigger issues I understand that they're
women that are survivors of rape and I
do understand the argument I understand
the side where we have to look at
everything we have to understand because
it's some way if women are truly angry
about this and then there must be
something to it
but at the same time you know I want to
see a woman who can who can stand strong
who can look at the song and say you
know what that's not going to bother me
I know what my boundaries are I know
when to leave for me I feel like it's
almost a step back to see all this rage
and anger over that where I want to see
women going you know what we recognize
the cultural differences or back then
and those in that time that that kind of
sucks for back then but thank God we are
where we are now and we're going to have
a voice